[Music]
foreign
it is better to live for one day as a
tiger than deliver a thousand years as a
lamb
[Music]
a child without education is Like a Bird
Without Wings
male and a hundred female qualities make
a perfect human being
[Music]
all the world's great Journeys begin
with the first step
imagination cures the chaos and the
Heart
[Music]
Thunder wants to see that many times to
hear
better than the young man's knowledge is
the old man's experience
[Music]
don't notice the tiny flea in the other
person's hair and Overlook the lumbering
Yak on your own nose
[Music]
don't trust a Hungry Man to watch your
rice
[Music]
each llama has his own teaching
eat according to the limits of your
Provisions walk according to the length
of your step
excellent people are honored wherever
they go
[Music]
goodness speaks in a whisper evil shouts
learn to stand up after you fall
if I know I will die tomorrow I can
still learn something today
luck that lasts is always suspect
if you eat a little or a lot of garlic
the smell is just as strong
only a certain amount of flowers and
jewels are beautiful
[Music]
if the inner mind is not deluded the
outer actions will not be wrong
if the master gets drunk it is an
honorable drunkenness if the servant
does it is evidence of his mean
disposition
[Music]
if there is only one earring among Seven
Daughters there will always be a quarrel
on Festival days
if you don't know where you are any road
will do
knowing just one word of wisdom is like
knowing a hundred ordinary words
rebellious thoughts are like an
abandoned house overtaken by robbers
[Music]
so good and you'll reap good so bad and
you'll re-bad
[Music]
you don't have to cut down a tree to get
its fruit
highest art is the Art of Living an
ordinary life in an extraordinary manner
that looks best on the head a flower
looks best in the grass
the wise understand by themselves the
fool follows the report of others
those who have saved one life have saved
the entire world
to change the world we must first change
ourselves
to spread the news is to multiply it
when a king is about to lose his power
his orders burn more intensely than fire
[Music]
words are mere bubbles of water Deeds or
drops of gold
[Music]
without an ax no tree can be cut down
medicine that heals is not always sweet
caring words are not always Pleasant
[Music]
watch your character it becomes your
destiny
[Music]
without a woman's help a man cannot set
up a tent
[Music]
a sore in the mouth must heal in the
mouth
[Music]
a person who gets stuck on Petty
happiness will not attain great
happiness
with a Resolute heart a mouse can lift
an elephant
the young Magpie that pulls feathers out
of his mother thinks that he is showing
gratitude
a beautiful lady may not work a lot
[Music]
a guest who speaks truthfully and a lord
who has good intentions are rare gems
a single thread doesn't make a cloth a
single tree doesn't make a forest
a trustworthy donkey should be given a
trustworthy load
discipline must be endured by oneself
before one sets others under it
a useless order is sent back to the king
a useless bride is sent back to her
mother's doorstep
ask others for opinions but decide on
your own
[Music]
at the site where the dance of
auspiciousness is danced don't dance the
dance of ill Omens
Frank words make listening easier
[Music]
even poison can be turned into medicine
even the smallest task is hard to
accomplish without effort
[Music]
for an honest leader Justice is
difficult
[Music]
he who is seen too close and heard too
often loses the respect of others
[Music]
rather than be the leader of a bad
public be the servant of a good master
if a problem cannot be solved with skill
then love and care will resolve it
[Music]
however prosperous 1B one shouldn't
spoil one's child
[Music]
it is better for close friends to have
some distance and for close neighbors to
have high walls between them
[Music]
it is better to plow a fertile field
than to build a house on it
not everything that is cooked is fit to
eat
[Music]
rather than build a monastery in the
Uplands live without disputes in the
lowlands
to fix your drinking habit look at the
drunkard
the blacksmith thinks making butter is
difficult the butter maker thinks
casting iron is difficult
[Music]
the bowl may break but its pattern lives
in one's mind
[Music]
a fool can be recognized by two signs he
talks a lot about things that are of no
use to him and he speaks out about
things he is not asked about
violently abused even a kind friendly
person becomes an enemy
the lone traveler's companion is his
shadow
[Music]
The Moth is killed by the flame the
greedy is killed by his avarice
the parrot is put into a cage for its
skill of speech
the other birds enjoy the freedom of the
sky
[Music]
when the race is on a cliff face a goat
is faster than a horse
[Music]
the thief May possess the ability to
steal but the owner May possess the
ability to protect his possessions
[Music]
times of struggle will sift the good
from the bad friends
[Music]
Pleasant conversation may be of some
help during times of Sorrow
[Music]
foreign